we mentioned eric
uh eric weinstein i know you agree on a
bunch of things is there some beautiful
fascinating insightful disagreement that
you have
that has yet to be resolved with him is
there some ideas do you guys battle
about battle it out on is it the
stagnation question that you mentioned
that's one of them but here's at least
two others
but i would stress eric is always
evolving so i'm just talking about a
time slice eric right
i don't know where he's at right now
yeah like i heard him on clubhouse three
nights ago but that was three nights ago
yeah
but i think he's far too pessimistic
about the impact of
immigration on u.s science he thinks it
has displaced u.s scientists
which i think that is partly true i just
think we've gotten better talent
i'm like bring it on double down and
look at kuriko you know who
basically came up with mrna vaccines she
was from hungary
and was ridiculed and mocked she
couldn't get her papers published
she stuck at it an american
might not have been so stubborn because
we have these cushions
so eric is all worried like
mathematicians coming in
they're discouraging native u.s citizens
from doing math
i'm like bring in the best people if we
all end up
in other avocations absolutely fine by
me does it trouble you that we
kick them out after they get a degree
often
i would give anyone with a plausible
graduate degree a green card
universally yeah that's i i agree with
that it makes no sense
it makes so strange that the best people
that come here suffer
here create awesome stuff here then when
we kick them out doesn't make any sense
here's another view i have i call it
open borders for belarus
now russia is a big country i would
gladly like increase the russian quota
by 3x 4x 5x like i
not 20 but a big boost but belarus
small country like why can't and they're
poor
and they have decent education and a lot
of talent there why can't we just open
the door
yeah and convert a belarus passport to a
green card
open borders for belarus it's my new
campaign slogan
are you running for president 2024 well
write-ins are welcome but
uh what's the what's the second thing
you disagree with eric
uh trade again i'm not sure where he's
at now
but he is suspicious of trade in a way
that i am not
i do understand what's called the china
shock has been a big problem for the u.s
middle class
i fully accept that i think most of that
is behind us
national security issues aside i think
free trade is
very much a good thing eric
i'm not sure he'll say it's not a good
thing but he won't say it is a good
thing
and i know he's kind of that's like eric
free trade
but look on things like vaccines i don't
believe in free trade
you want vaccine production in your own
country look at the eu
they have enough money no one will send
them vaccines
what's different about vaccines is it
there are some things you want to
prioritize the citizenry on
and i would argue it would be cheaper to
produce all u.s manufactured vaccines in
india
they have the technologies uh obviously
lower wages
but look there's talk in india right now
of cutting off the export of vaccines
if you outsource your vaccine production
you're not sure the other country will
respect the norm of free trade
so you need to keep some vaccine
production in your country
it's an exception to free trade not to
the logic
a bunch of things the navy uses you
can't buy those components from china
like that's insane
but look it would be cheaper to do so
right yeah
you